you helped pull me back from the
darkness
you are always with me
[Music]
[Music]
it's starting
if only they knew what was coming first
question i wanted to ask you after
watching the first few episodes of
season six is um it got me thinking
if jamie actually the roles were
reversed and jamie had been the one to
time travel and end up in the 1940s how
do you think he would have done and this
is a question for both of you and do you
think they would have fallen in love
if they had just sort of met by chance
given that she was married um but if
they had spent some time together was it
just the inevitable
wow yeah i wonder how he would have done
in 1940s but um yeah i mean i think it's
inevitable isn't it but um i know that
diana was very very firmly set that
jamie will never or could never travel
um he doesn't have the doesn't have the
gene right um but i think um
yeah this is an uh
a romance or a a love story that well
does span it does span you know decades
and hundreds of years so um yeah i think
they were meant to be together
don't you
yeah i don't think he'd be a very good
driver i think that's one of the things
he yeah he'd be on horseback
he'd be like trying to whip the car
trying to get it to move you know
um
you know of course i think they would
find each other i think this is a
metaphysical love story that um
spans time and space and
their soul mates right so
they'd be like the lobsters they'd find
each other
i think about this all the time as i
watch the series i can't help myself
what message is jb there to deliver what
much is his ghost there to deliver do
you guys think about it and do you think
about how the series is going to end up
like the fans do
oh
are you talking about the ghost at the
start yeah
do we notice jaime's ghost i think that
i think they've revealed that yeah
yeah i think you revealed that sam
yeah yeah um
well i don't know how it's going i mean
i do know actually diana has shared with
me the the like the last chapter
um
and uh
yeah
you'll have to keep watching to find out
but um yeah i don't want to know
spoilers but what was your reaction when
she told you were you surprised
um
i just like how we're gonna have to get
there right i mean there's so much
there's so much more to tell so much
more of the story and you know every
season we try and uh you know fit in as
much as we can but we can never cover
everything in the books but um
we're getting there you know diana's
just released her her last book and
she's got one more to go but um well i'm
sure she won't stop she'll keep going
but but uh it's been such a great
journey to go on from that very first
moment actually it was one of the first
things i think i shot um to to now you
know it feels like we've come so far uh
on this and yet yeah there's still a
long way to go yet
katrina i know you were both producers
on this season
um what was your biggest takeaway from
being a producer on the show is there
anything that you really fought
to have into the season and how does
this season differentiate itself from
other seasons
um well i think one of the things that
was more apparent this season than ever
was just the
practical
challenges and complications of filming
and i think that's something that sam
and i really
sort of got more involved in or relished
sort of getting more into those
conversations this season you know our
our writer's room and our producers were
in the states
we had one of our writer producers on
set but other than that nobody really
could come because of covid
um so sam and i were there on the floor
day to day and it was really
you know you get more of an insight into
what those challenges are and how we how
we can help you know how we can help be
the liaison between crew or we can help
see what needs to be maybe improved or
whatever
um
and in terms of stories i think
you know it's more about
shaping things you know i think our
writers do such a great job but there
are times when you feel that maybe
you have
a stronger insight to maybe what your
character is going through and and you
want to sort of highlight maybe uh
that voice more than
than say another take on it so
i think there was just stuff it was more
just collaborating with the writers and
trying to
to keep it very true to the character i
think i cannot be two things at once
clear
rebel
a loyalist
agent for the crown and an enemy of the
king
you can't live your life afraid of being
who you are
my first question to both of you
congratulations on season six i'm
richard i know you joked during the
pandemic you said that you would really
love the idea of doing a spoof on
outlander where you all switch roles i
don't know if you remember saying it or
not but if you were to do that which
role would you would each of you choose
i think it every day
every day
and every day my answer changes although
i think i'd like to play brianna i'd
really like to give my valley girl twist
on brianna
i think that could be quite interesting
and a lot of fun are to demonstrate
should be like hey guys i've invented
matches how clever am i i can start
fires wherever i go
wanna see
i just want to point out that this isn't
a thing that he would like to do he does
this on set every single day
it's like i say aligner and there's this
echo valley girl version where richard
is taking the vic out of me it's like
okay
there he is okay so retaliation which
one are you two who are you choosing
well i wouldn't say roger because i even
if i took the makeup of roger i'd never
hear the end of it and richard would
just rinse me for my scottish accent so
even if it was perfect so um
i think i'd play rollo because that
dudes he's just having a blast he just
runs around the fields just doesn't
listen to anyone runs through shots
just living the life
got it okay so um the pb and j scene
last season it kind of made me think
like when you guys are all together
because there's a lot of scenes where
you're all together a lot of seasons
when you're off on your own for a fly on
the wall and fans of this series can you
sort of break down
that scene and what is going on paint us
a picture
well first of all the peanut butter is
extra sticky and so if we took a bite
and then you're trying to say a line it
just it wasn't working um and also
katrina and i always seem to be the two
in those scenes the rituals fought me on
this where we we eat a lot at the
beginning and then obviously for
continuity purposes once you've eaten a
lot in one take you have to eat a lot
every other day and so then we're always
tripping ourselves up because the food's
always amazing we have this friendship
and he's awesome and it always tastes so
good and when it's wasted and no one's
touched it i feel really bad for him so
we make a point of trying to have a bit
of everything and then by the end of the
day you're actually just like oh connie
another fight oh is that your excuse
sophie that you feel bad for the chef is
that why
yeah
i know you've joked that roger has
changed so much from season one that you
almost think that the two of them met
they wouldn't get along
can you sort of break down how that
meeting would go and which one would you
personally rather hang with
what a great question i'm not really
sure
answer that nikki without being quite
damning to myself and my character um
how would that mean go i mean roger of
season six is obviously a lot more
experienced
um
in terms of the world in which he lives
he's definitely how they are he's been
through a lot he's probably quite
psychologically damaged um
so i think i'm not sure how much time he
would have although you know they have
history to connect with don't they so
they'd probably get on along for a while
until rogers of the 18th century decided
that roger of the 60s was maybe a bit of
a wet blanket and you know before
advising him to go home and have a cup
of tea and get to bed early
i don't feel like season six roger would
tell season two or just just like me
she's amazing stop messing it up just no
no
it's going to come into your life quite
soon at your father's funeral um stay
clear over run
go back to oxford find a nice you know
find a nice young girl at oxford marry
her and have a happy quiet life that's
probably what he would say
if america doesn't become america who
knows what that world will look like
what would that mean for a family the
clock is ticking
first of all i want to jump in
without spoilers the first few episodes
of this season the two of you
have a scene that could kind of rival
jamie and claire in terms of
love things you think so thank you for
thinking that nikki
oh my god
thoughts feelings emotions when you read
that part of the script and then
actually acting it out
that's such a good question lauren you
want to go first
when we first read it i think both of us
were like
why
why
yeah we had a couple questions uh the
rise
and we were like can we have a call
let's have a call everyone so we had a
call um
by the end of it i mean like the two of
us are best friends and we are really
comfortable with each other and we
worked all out beforehand
um everything is prosthetic which is
delightful and is really
helpful
in that scenario i mean i'm pregnant so
like these change when that happens so
that was really helpful and i think we
both were like feeling very blessed for
that so um
yeah it was great we i i
my face wasn't prosthetic though
but no it's it's a tricky one because
like we we often talk about but that's
that's what's lovely about outlander you
know you're telling a story about 18th
century uh trufino so of course we had
this call and it was so nice to talk to
marilyn matt that would explain us so
precisely and beautifully why we were
doing that and actually as an actor um
you want to do like difficult
challenging things that was one because
like we wanted like to
you know you go from one place with that
scene exact scene from one place to
another but we wanted it to make it like
look cute and not weird not like um
one-sided um
so it was a bit of a dance
but i think we yeah we we found a rhythm
doing it
um
and i'm happy if it looks cool
beautiful scene it really i've watched
the whole series and it really stands
out to me you both are doing beautiful
work um at the end of season um five
you got to participate in the 60s
sequence i know you both had a lot of
fun doing it it kind of made me think
that how would marceli and fergus do if
they were actually transposed in the 60s
how would their relationship do and how
would they each do as individuals would
they do well do you think yeah i think
they were meant for the 60s you know
what i think actually i remember when i
put on like i was given loads of vintage
like a rail of just beautiful vintage
clothes to try on and one of the first
ones i tried on was the yellow dress and
everyone was like uh that's perfect i
think this is all meant for you and we'd
walk on set and everyone would be like
you guys are meant for now like this is
this is where you all look comfortable
um i much prefer it to
like not wearing a corset and a baby
bump and a bum roll and like have my
whole body different like that's really
nice that was really fun to do um but
yeah it was it was great we had so much
fun filming those days despite the fact
that it was quite like a dark
sequence to have you think about i think
everyone really respected it and was
really aware of what we were doing but
there's also got to be levity on days
like that where you have to you have to
enjoy yourself and we had to also
like you know act
it was a happy time it was a happy night
that we were experiencing for the
downfall to then really have the impact
it needed to have so we did have fun
i've been watching the show i'm always
theorizing how it's going to end
how you know what was jamie's ghost
there to say what was the message do you
each have a theory
yourselves about where your characters
end up and how it ends do you think
about it and do you have a theory for
for season six or four the end of the
whole series because i know it hasn't
necessarily been written yet so lauren
and i are not reading the bookstore to
come because we
for many reasons but we have something
that is lovely we have amazing fans that
we end up meeting at fan conventions and
it's like we have these like super
precious interaction with them where
they're like they they okay i would
start like that jesus being like stuff
happened to you in book nine and i'm
like what tell me and it's so cute
because i end up talking to um a woman
that is a fan of outlander of us from
chicago or somewhere and it would be
like
and she has so appetite to tell me like
oh this happens to you and this and that
and that i'm like but how old am i
supposed to be in this book she's like
45 and i'm but i'm never going to be 45.
i really do that
they just keep being like you've not
died yet you're still alive you're not
dead
like yeah so we love that
we love that um
but uh i'm actually very much looking
forward to it but
but i have good hopes because like
already i love how not linear the story
is you know i would really love them to
get to go through the stones i thought
that would be fun oh yeah
if you're reading the books but i know
that we might learn more about where
fergus is actually from whose fergus dad
is actually
and this is a big surprise but i cannot
say more if you guys did don't jump to
2022 because i think you're the most
modern characters what would be each of
your favorite movie
do you think or would you be into
reality tv what would be the thing
your character's meaning okay yeah
i mean i mean
i want to say i want to say belfast
because i saw it two days ago my
character is so loves cleveland
barcelona so much she doesn't want to
watch her life essentially and then
belfast
yeah and i'm right now is good
so good
what would their favorite film be
titanic no i don't know i really don't
know actually
actually the boat ain't a cute hot young
couple why not actually titanic is smart
lauren because they could remember the
boot somehow somewhere from a past life
you know what i mean they fell in love
on a boat kind of you know
so
he would share the raft
yeah there would be enough enough room
for them too like for sure
i don't belong here
briana roger they don't belong here
but yet here we are
all of us because i loved you
more than the life that i've had
and this i promise you won't come
between us
congratulations saw the first two
episodes of season six um and i know you
sort of every season you sort of tease
there's like one word to describe the
whole season this season you're using
the word revolution which um and either
one of you can answer this question
which character do you think
changes the most this season and which
relationship of the key marriages
changes the most this season without
spoilers as much as best as you can tell
us
wow i i think um
the changes probably happen to
um
marceline fergus have
some massive massive changes going on in
their
life and the relationship um
i think for for you know claire and
jamie
relationship wise they're just steadfast
that's the way we see them in in the
writer's room it's it's you know with
that never has this you know how do we
break them up that doesn't come up you
know it's what do we throw at them you
know what parts of the book do we take
and we show we throw this at their
relationship and watch them endure watch
them you know try to stay together you
know against all odds um so
they don't really change in that regard
who they are it's just um how they how
they struggle to to survive their world
and and i think what you hit on of the
revolution this season is both
revolution um
in the world
yeah the world's going through a
revolution but also their community in
their home at fraser's ridge is going
through a revolution with the new
visitors that have arrived and um you
saw them so uh
oh my gosh the new cast is amazing and i
thought it's interesting of the first
two episodes i thought could there maybe
be trouble for jamie and claire in the
sense of it's the first time she's ever
held anything back from him that she's
not telling him something but i'd love
to hear that they're very steadfast i'm
meryl a question for you and you both
talked about this before how it gets um
the books as they go along
get more into the characters feelings
than that and sometimes it's hard to
dramatize so you had the 60s sequence at
the end of season five um what could you
tease for season six will we see those
type of visuals or how do you provide
that sort of visual for fans um in
season six times travel
yeah it's funny i mean last year we took
a swing at the fences with a few things
i think in terms of visually kind of
different looking episodes i don't think
matt unless i'm wrong i don't think we
do give anything
quite like that you know obviously and
certainly
we do
we do
we do
i think that last year kind of opened
the door a little bit uh mickey in the
sense that we we
you kind of hit on it in that
diana's books are very internal there's
a lot of emotions and thoughts inside
you know claire and jamie so to visually
show that and we stepped out of the box
last year and we're trying it a little
bit again this year with uh there's a
couple episodes that we do that um
and uh it's later in the season and and
you know it's trying to visualize
emotions that's exactly right i see what
you're saying no i was thinking a whole
episode necessarily that like we did
with the roger hanging but he's right i
think we did try something
he put it better than i did visualizing
some emotions that i think
um
is really interesting and um i think we
all are very excited about them
producers i think um i don't know i'm
afraid which one of you said it but that
you basically you make these shows and
you adapt those books as best you can
and you put it out to the world and then
the world reacts how do you infuse
the reaction do you read do you not like
to read it sort of how do you sort of
get that fan feedback and feedback
to the show i read it like this no i um
i actually love it i you know i say it
all the time we have the best fans in
the world yes occasionally you get some
people who don't like what you do it's
it's natural and there are shows i don't
like i mean we all have an opinion it's
very subjective but honestly i love that
feedback i love hearing what people
thought um
everywhere it's just exciting you you
live with this for so long i mean matt
and i both you know this is a year-round
job we just finished editing on this
season like a month ago so it's still
fresh in our minds and it is hard to
send your baby out into the world and
and have people judge it but i just love
it i love this whole time of year where
people are just starting to see the
episodes and every week you get new
responses so we have the best fans in
the world so it's it's always fun
and i i always say that it's the the
show isn't done until the audience sees
it so that's when it's finished to me
this audience absolutely loved the first
two episodes so thank you for another
brilliant season and thanks for the chat